all right welcome everyone
again we have a very full day the plan
is to finish up our review of core
information retrieval stuff the focus
will be on neural information retrieval
where a lot of the action is these days
uh have been a few data sets to show you
and then I'm going to turn it over to
Sid and sin is Sid is going to help us
talk again about how to build fantastic
language models
so let's dive in we'll start by using
our big handout here information
retrieval
right and so here we are and we are
going to skip uh that's right I had a
couple more metrics that I wanted to
show you so let's start there so last
time we talked about how
assessment in the space of ir should be
multi-dimensional
and we've been focused on accuracy but I
will make amends we are going to circle
back and talk about these other
dimensions which I regard as absolutely
crucial in this space
but with that said we did dive into
different metrics we talked about
success and reciprocal rank success you
should think of as just saying for My
Chosen k
is there a star above me that is is
there a relevant document above k
so it's a very coarse grain measure so
this one here if we set success at 2 D1
as success because there is a star at 2
or above
D2 that ranking also has a successive
one because there is a star to or above
and poor D3 gets a success of zero
and you can see already that it's coarse
grained because D1 and D2 are
differentiated in some intuitive sense
but here they both got a success score
of one
reciprocal rank is a little bit better
in the sense that it's more or less just
registering whether there's a star at or
above K except now we are sensitive to
the top most ranked one so for example
D1 here has an RR at two of one
because there is a star in first place
whereas D2 has one over two because the
first star is in second place
and then D3 still gets its four zero
so pretty coarse grain but very
intuitive and sometimes success and RR
are good metrics in the sense that you
kind of just want to know for your
chosen K whether you hit the mark
whether you got a star and especially if
you only have one relevant document per
query you might as well use these
metrics
and then RR will just be a little bit
more nuanced
we also talked about precision and
recall the classic accuracy style
metrics in this space the differentiator
here from the previous ones is that
these are going to be sensitive to
multiple Stars so if you have more than
one document that's irrelevant to your
query you will be able to detect that
so we have this notion of a return value
that is just a set of documents K or
above and then the relevant documents
those are the ones with stars and
precision is saying for My Chosen k
what percentage of the things at or
above K are relevant
and that's Precision in the sense that
if you picked K you're looking at the
set of documents and you want to know
how many of them have stars relative to
the total
or like the reversal Precision would be
like which ones are kind of imprecise as
predictions because there's no star
there
and then recall is kind of the Duel of
that and it says for My Chosen K how
many of the stars made it up to K or
above and the opposite of that would be
like how many stars are lingering down
below
so you can see here because of the
numerator that we're going to
differentiate systems now based on how
many stars are at K or above so it's
sensitive to multiple Stars
so just to walk through again Precision
at 2 for D1 is two out of two
for D2 it's one out of two because just
half of them have a star and for poor D3
0 out of two
recall is very similar but now the
denominator changes right so the recall
at two for this first one is two out of
three that is of the three star
documents two are at K or above
here it's one out of three and here at
zero out of three
and just to round this out poor D3 has
not fared well in our ranking so far
but in a surprise twist if I change the
value of K to 5 all of the sudden D3
looks pretty good
because now it's got all three of its
stars at five or above whereas the other
two
even though they've got some high Stars
up there we're not sensitive to that
precisely and so now D3 has pulled the
head
and that is maybe something that you
want to watch out for because people
kind of innocently choose these K values
when they're evaluating systems and I
just showed you that that could you know
really impact the ranking of systems and
in particular
like
you know it's hard to imagine since
there are only six documents but if it
was a lot of work to travel down to our
chosen K if K was a thousand
this would obscure the fact that we
might pick as our winner A system that
had all the stars more or less at a
thousand and the other systems which
have their Stars at the top of this
ranking and therefore they're easy to
find those might be diminished with such
a high k
and so that kind of gets you into the
role of thinking what are my users
trying to do what is the cost of them
scanning down a list of ranked results
and things like that and that's where I
want you to be when you think about
these metrics what are you trying to
solve out there in the world what are
your users confronting what is the cost
of reviewing examples and so forth and
so on
yeah
neural IR models that we're going to
kind of solve this problem of right
because right now everything's based on
the presence or not a word
rather than kind of maybe a either a
longer meaning or
um like the quality of the relevance
however we Define it like maybe it only
says the word once but it actually has
the best information afterwards will
that take care of that or is all of your
also going to be based on presence or
not upwards that's a great question ah
wait we should be careful so yeah I
think for the first part of your
question I want to say the neural IR
models are overall going to be better
because of what you alluded to they have
a very rich semantic space
it won't directly impact this because
these Stars after all aren't about terms
this is about whether a whole document
was relevant to a query you should
imagine that the background process is
like some team of humans went through
and said okay you searched for Bert
and now I'm going through documents and
saying yeah this one is relevant this
one isn't that's what produced these
rankings
but I think you're right in your core
intuition term-based models are going to
be kind of brittle and if we have hard
query document pairs they might miss
them actually that reminds me like I
this for some reason it didn't display
before let's see if it displays now I
had this nice example that Omar created
this is an example of why search is a
hard nlu problem because this is a query
what compounds protect the digestive
system against viruses where the
response is certainly relevant but there
is zero relevant term overlap between
query and document all of the
connections that we want to make are
deeply semantic connections and I do
think that that is why neural IR models
have pulled ahead
for accuracy style assessments trying to
be careful as you'll see
I have one more metric
which is average precision and this will
be this is fair to say our most nuanced
metric okay so a little bit hard to
think about but I think it's intuitive
average Precision notice it has no k
and the reason it has an okay is that
we're going to sum over all the
Precision values for different K's here
where there is a relevant document think
back to our rankings wherever there was
a star we're going to choose that as a k
and we're going to sum up just those
Precision values and divide it by the
number of relevant documents
here's an example same three rankings
that we had before and what I'll show
you are these Precision calculations so
for the first one we have stars at
position one two and six
and so we accumulate the Precision
values for one two and six
and those are I hope the ones I've given
there that sums to 2.5
and then we divide that by three which
is the number of relevant documents
so we've abstracted away the K which is
reassuring and we're also checking at
every level so it's not going to have
that sensitivity I showed you before
where the choice of K dramatically
impacts which rankings we favor because
now we're kind of looking at all of the
ones chosen by the ranking
so that's D1 and then for D2 same thing
but now we're checking it 2 5 and 6
because that's where the stars are and
that sums to 1.4
and then for D3 we do the same thing at
positions three four and five and notice
interestingly that D3 has a pulled ahead
of D2
that's less surprising to me in the
current context because
D2
is kind of good and kind of not right it
has that one star that's near the top
but the other two stars are way at the
bottom of our ranking whereas at least
D3 kinda put them all at least not
literally at the bottom
whereas D1 looks like just a slam dunk
winner here I mean it simply has most of
the Stars right at the top it has that
one only one at the bottom but you know
on balance D1 looks good so if I just
stepped back from this little example I
would say that average Precision is kind
of nice in terms of giving what looks to
me like a pretty nuanced picture of
these three rankings
thank you
I think that's all of the accuracy style
metrics of course there are others that
you'll encounter some are sensitive to
the numerical like the float value
because sometimes you have not just a
one or a zero a star or not but rather a
float value for relevance
there are lots of versions that of
course average these over sets of
queries that'll be very common to see
but underlyingly that's just some kind
of arithmetic average of these scores so
I think this is a good sample are there
questions I can answer about these
metrics
relevance
how's that at a high level computing
computed oh it's called like the
discounted cumulative gain
and it is the sum of all of the scores
divided by something or other this must
be in your history somewhere
or not persevering maybe a good position
Maybe a combination of human labels
oh so you found the discounted
cumulative gain that's a metric I left
out
and then you're just observing that very
often for these data sets we'd have
humans do a bunch of labeling and then
average Precision is one way of
aggregating over the labels we might
have collected
I kind of alluded to this before but
like here's a partial list of things you
could think about which metric
fundamentally there is no single answer
is the cost of Co scrolling through K
passages low
then maybe success at K is fine because
you don't care whether it was a position
nine or position one what you really
care about is that the user is kind of
confronted with the success that they
can easily find right that's one
scenario that you could be in
are there multiple relevant documents
per query this is straightforward if so
you probably shouldn't use success at K
or rrk because they're only sensitive
really to one star and if you went to
the trouble of getting multiple Stars
you know why have your metric be
insensitive to that
so that seems clear
is it more important to find every
relevant document if so you should favor
recall that would be a case where maybe
human review is cheap or the cost of
missing an example is hugely expensive
in that case you want to favor recall
you can't miss anything conversely if
you just need to find some relevant
things maybe in an ocean of examples
because you want to label them or
because it's just good to know about
them then you could favor Precision
because then all you really care about
is that near the top are some relevant
things
F1 at K is the harmonic mean of
precision and recall same thing as we do
in NLP and that can be used where there
are multiple relevant documents but
maybe the relative order above K doesn't
matter that's just one perspective on
what I mean when I say we're combining
precision and recall
and then finally average Precision of
the ones I've showed you will give you
the most fine-grained distinctions of
the metrics right because it's sensitive
to rank
and it's sensitive to precision and
recall Precision because it Aggregates
over those values and recall because
that's the denominator
so that looks like an awfully good way
to really get a fine-grained ranking of
systems
and then finally I'm going to talk about
this a bit later we have to move on
Beyond accuracy this is a paper that I
did with a team recently of researchers
here and at IBM what we're seeing here
is a kind of post-hoc leaderboard not an
actual leaderboard because part of our
complaint is that there are no
leaderboards that really do anything
beyond measuring accuracy style things
but if you did go through the literature
as we did here and find a lot of systems
you can see that they vary widely along
other dimensions here is the mean
reciprocal rank one of our rankings goes
from 19 to 37 and you are 39 or
something so you say okay but then look
just to the right of that at the query
latency
to get to 37 look how much time I have
to spend versus down here where 36 I
spend a fraction of the time
that is absolutely something that will
matter to the search experience of users
uh there isn't almost no way they're
waiting around for 691 milliseconds
for example or what about the index size
right if you care about space footprint
and you will if you are indexing the web
some of these have tiny little indices
and then uh oh that's our model Colbert
V1 154 gigabytes
right so now if you need to hold it in
memory your world just got a lot more
expensive
uh and you'll see over here Ram
requirements so bm25
it has no Hardware requirements at all
you can run that on anything whereas
these models down here that have these
really high mrr scores hugely expensive
in terms of compute classic story of the
neural age right so you have to pay
somewhere
and then of course I hope you're
thinking about this so then what is the
best combination of all these things
well it depends on how much money you
have and how much time you have and how
much you care about accuracy
and so the best pitch I can make to you
is that as you evaluate systems you
think about what you care about what
matters and conduct construct your
evaluations on that basis that's going
to be a big theme of the course later on
and I'm hoping to time it so that you
all for your papers are thinking about
assessment and you think ah you know I
should have a whole section about my
philosophy of assessment here and not
just fall into F1 or fall into success
at K or whatever is relevant
this is kind of interesting too this is
from the same paper
here's bm25
costs essentially nothing but it has
very low performance if you travel
straight up from there look at these
blade models also costing essentially
nothing but vastly better in terms of
their performance that looks like a real
Discovery to me you know this is like
the Pareto Frontier as they call it
these systems where you would just
wouldn't choose any that are off the
frontier no matter what your values and
obviously you can see that to favor this
model
they're going to have to be other
dimensions that we care about Beyond
cost and mrr because otherwise that's
just not a choice you would make
but for all I know there are hidden
Dimensions that need to be teased out
that would show that that ants model is
the best
relative to
let's dive into some of those models
then neural IR
first we'll start with cross encoders
this will be very intuitive okay here
just imagine I have a huge Transformer
and four cross encoders what I do is I
just concatenate the query and the
document together
process them with my Transformer model
and then on the top here I put a little
scoring function and the scoring
function will just say
for this query how good is this document
enormously powerful to this comment from
before we are making like maximal use of
this say Bert model here to get every
possible interaction between query and
document
so this would be good in terms of
accuracy
but you might worry about some other
things here let me walk through a bit
more in the background here I'm assuming
that our data set looks like this we
have a query
one positive document and a set of one
or more negative documents
we could have multiple of the negatives
what I'm depicting on the left here is a
model we could summarize like this this
is the encoder
we concatenate the query in the document
and process them and we retrieve this
representation here layer n position
zero
we feed that through a dense layer that
does our scoring and that is the basis
for essentially a classifier
this is called the negative log
likelihood of the positive passage and
if you squint or you don't squint you
just let it go blurry you will see that
it is a typical classifier loss
the only possible twist is the numerator
is the positive passage score
and then on the denominator I have the
positive passage summed together with
all the negative passages that I have in
my example set
but fundamentally it's a classifier
and so that's why this examples look
like this because that's what's being
used here to optimize all these
parameters to score documents
final thing
I hope you're thinking about this it's
going to be incredibly expressive and
Powerful but it just won't scale
the cost of having the query and
document interact at query time is that
I can't process any of these documents
ahead of time so just imagine this your
query comes in on the web like your
Google you're using a cross encoder the
user queries you need to process that
query together with every single
document on the web
to score them and then on that basis you
will get beautiful scores
but obviously each query could take
years to serve
so from this perspective it is just not
a practical choice
maybe we could use it for re-ranking you
see this sometimes where a cheap
retriever gets a lot of like like a
thousand documents and then this is done
to re-rank the last thousand but we
can't do this at web scale
so a question in the back yeah
positive documents as well
um
let's see I don't see why not the
numerator could be the sum of the
positive and then the denominator could
just include all of those so that what
you would be doing is
well
I'm just trying to think through that
that would be one approach the other
approach would be to just treat them as
separate examples
I think under some conditions those will
be identical but I'd have to think it
through but
I don't see a problem I don't see a
problem
but it's worth thinking about I'll get
back to you on that
let's improve on this DPR dense passage
retriever this will also be intuitive
here we go query and document except
notice now they are processed by
separate models the query encoder and
the document encoder could be the same
parameters but the point is we process
them separately and I've made lighter
every state except the output tokens but
below the two class tokens
because those are the only ones that we
need okay these two
and then we do some kind of scoring on
that basis like similarity right so here
our examples are the same
now the similarity function as I'm
calling it for for a query in a document
is we process the query we get this guy
process the document and we get this the
guy and then we do scoring on that basis
there are no additional parameters we
just score based on those
representations their dot product
so now
we've got something that is highly
scalable because we can process every
document in our entire web collection
into a single Vector this one and it can
just sit there on disk and then at query
time process the query get its vector
and do this super fast dot product
comparison for scoring
so now we've got something that is
probably even going to function as a
full ranking model not just a re-ranker
but the real gain is that we can process
all our documents offline the cost was
that we now have almost no interactions
between the query and the document like
if you think about token identities if
you think about the soft matching that
happens with tfidf none of that is going
to be able to happen here
that was the cost
yeah
so uh I mean essentially what we've been
comparing would be two pixel vectors
right I mean a vector representing the
document another difference so is there
I mean a limit to the length of the
document that could be represented in
that vectors I mean like put it
represent an arbitrary in Long document
a good lose context these are great
questions let me repeat them for the
first question yes you are right the one
constraint we need to impose on the
query encoder and the document encoder
is that they have the same
dimensionality so that we can do the dot
product they can otherwise be separate
models if we want and then length of
query and length of document that's just
going to be imposed by whatever we
choose for the query in the document
themselves so if you choose Bert you're
going to be stuck with 512 as the
longest document that you can process
unless we do some further manipulation
of these things
yeah
um if these models are trained to
project into kind of like a shared
embedding space so like documents that
are similar to a query you're gonna fall
into a similar location and embedding
space
could we have a system where we
essentially take like we pre-process all
the documents we take a query at
inference time
projected into embedding space and then
do like a New York City research or
something like that
yes well yes so some aspects of what
you're describing I think are what DPR
will be optimized for the other parts of
what you're saying are going to be
optimization tricks that I show you in a
second I believe
yes what do you mean by limited query
doc interactions
just that all we've got in the end is
this Vector for the whole query and this
Vector for the whole document so token
identities to the extent that they're
preserved at all they have to have been
packed into those vectors
whereas over here
we had every token level interaction you
can imagine as a result of us using like
the transformer
foreign
I think that's a natural follow-on is
that you might think I want to have in
this layer here some additional
parameters and you can kind of see how
that might work right so instead of just
using this Vector I would put some
parameters on top and then the same
optimization could be used yeah
attention
yeah yeah
and that this could be good in the sense
that we we would pay a little bit of a
cost by adding more parameters but we
might gain something in terms of
expressivity
let me show you a happy compromise
oh yeah I just wanted to point this out
um that I've just showed you two loss
functions I showed you the cross encoder
and the DPR and you can probably already
see that they are identical except for
this function that you might call comp
here
and that's kind of freeing and as you
think about these different model
architectures probably what you're
thinking about is simply changing this
comp function and then using your
available data to train the model
against this negative log likelihood of
the positive Passage
there are other losses out there in the
literature but this is the most widely
used and it seems to be very effective
Colbert
this stands for contextualized late
interaction with Bert
it was invented by Omar and mate who are
here Omar is my student I work closely
with mate
and let's see so Omar would want you to
know
that this stands for contextualized late
interaction and he pronounces it Colbert
because Stephen Colbert has a show full
of contextualized late night
interactions
but you can also pronounce it Colbert
it's your choice because the bird there
is the Bert model
and we are yes still hoping that Stephen
Colbert will take notice of this
I haven't been so bold but I welcome you
all to do that
it's great Adam on Twitter yes
here's how this will work I've drawn the
query encoder on the side for reasons
that you'll see but it's the same kind
of thing so imagine Bert processes my
query and I've grayed out everything but
the final representations because
crucially those are the only ones that
we actually need
same thing with the document and it
could be the same encoder now what I'm
going to do with Colbert is form a grid
of scores
and this is going to essentially give
the similarity value between every query
token and every document token
and then I will choose the values along
the rows that is for each query the
document token that maximizes that
similarity comparison and the scoring
function is essentially the sum
of those three max values that is why
you see Max Sim all over the place for
Colbert
examples are as before
losses as before and I wrote down here
what we would think of as the com
function and I wrote it as Maxim for a
query and a document you sum over all
the query tokens and you get the max
matching document token
so you can see why it's contextualized
laid in Direction because I'm using the
output States
but unlike DPR I'm allowing them all to
interact with each other via these very
fast Maxim calculations
I have token level interactions that's
right so highly scalable and highly
expressive the only cost is that the
interactions happen only in this very
thin final layer
but this is really pleasing for IR
that Colbert because of this brings us
back to common intuitions in IR we do
genuinely achieve with these Maxim
scores intuitive soft alignments here I
have the query when did the Transformers
cartoon series come out
and the response document the animated
Transformers was released in August 1986
and these are proportional to actual
Maxim values query relative to document
the thickness of that line and you can
see that it is doing something very
intuitive and also something very
semantic because unlike turn-based
models I don't have to do anything
special to capture the fact that com in
the context of come out is a lot like
released
and similarly with when and that date
here I'm showing the two topmost Maxim
values and they're also very intuitive
and this is wonderful because IR has
been so successful for so long doing
term matching and it is nice to see that
intuition carried forward into this more
semantic space in my view
so I'll hand go up yeah
um is that Matrix of like query and
document mappings is that why the memory
index is
yes so your question is why is the index
for Colbert so big it is because we have
to store every token level
representation yes I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you that we can do better but
naively storing these for our entire
document store is going to be a lot of
vectors
one per token not one per type
one per token
yeah
pay somewhere I guess that's the Insight
yeah Yeah question maybe there's some
intuition that can make this a little
clearer if the document has multiple
variants of Transformers or you know
Decepticon Optics crime or whatever
they're all related to the original
token Transformers would you be able to
kind of draw that link to all those
other tokens as well or would you have
to think
I guess
one relationship Transformers is
represented once
I think that's a great question so
Transformers that's why I picked it it's
amusingly ambiguous between our model
and the animated cartoon series
um of my youth
so but I think the point is that because
it's Bert
Transformers in this context will have a
very different representation from the
one if we were talking about NLP and
that's why it's so good that we are
using Bert because then we'll get maxims
that are appropriately semantic that is
the Hope yeah whereas turn-based models
really going to struggle the best
they're going to be able to do is have
engrams that kind of capture the fact
that this Transformers is the cartoon
series one
so another actually that's another
argument in favor of being in a more
semantic space
I want to just quickly talk with you
about how we have worked to optimize
Colbert because I think that this
suggests things that you would want to
do if you developed your own neural
retrieval models because the hard truth
here is that bm25 is blazingly fast and
scalable and these neural models are not
you have to work much harder to get them
to that point of being as performant in
terms of other dimensions Beyond
accuracy
we could use Colbert as a re-ranker as I
alluded to before right so here I have
all these token level representations
which I do have to store
and they're each connected to a document
now on if used naively this will be not
scalable but I could do this given some
query uh that's represented as a
sequence of tokens
I could get the top K documents for it
using like bm25 and then re-rank that
top cam
and so if K is small I pay the full
price of the Colbert model but only for
K documents
and you're hoping that the M25 did a
good job of getting you to that initial
point
it's a very common application and it
can be really meaningful to re-rank that
final set of K documents
but we could do a little better if we
wanted to use Colbert end to end here's
how we could work we again store all
those token level vectors but now we're
going to kind of turn things around we
just need to keep track of those vectors
and their Associated documents
for a query that we have encoded as a
set of vectors using Colbert
we take each query Vector wi and we
retrieve the pmos token vectors from
this huge list that are similar to our
Target and that doesn't require the full
Colbert model that could just be a
similarity calculation and you can do
those really fast people have really
optimized that and then you get all the
documents associated with this small set
of vectors that you found and you score
them
so again the name of the game is to use
Colbert only very sparingly in a final
stage because it is so expensive
and then a third step here just quickly
we can do even better and this is quite
striking what we can do is cluster our
token level representations into their
centroids using k-means clustering
that's what I've got in red here
and then use them as the basis for
search so again we encode our query into
a series of vectors and then for this
target Vector wi we first get the
centroids that are closest to that and
this is important because in practice we
can collect only like four centroids per
token vector and do really well
that's a tiny number then we get the T
most similar token vectors to that
centroid
and then we finally do scoring on the
associated documents
and so by Leaps and Bounds here we have
reduced the amount of compute we need to
do with this huge index by using the
centroids and then using Colbert again
very sparingly
final thing and then I'll take some
questions the team has worked very hard
to reduce the latency of Colbert
this is a latency analysis here and the
thing I want to point out to you is that
the Colbert model steps actually for
this second version the one I just
described to you with the centroids that
was actually a relatively small part of
the overall cost because it was being
used so sparingly the big costs were
being in the dealing with the huge index
and also doing work to quantize the
vectors so that they were easier to
store on disk by making them smaller
and so after a bunch of work with this
framework called plaid they were able to
get rid of almost all of that index
lookup and dequantization or
decompression steps for the vectors that
were costing so much and they brought
the latency down to like 58 milliseconds
which so it went from something that is
impossible to imagine deploying
industrially to something that is close
to what you might entertain as a
possibility for deployment
and I you know the details are in the
Plaid paper we can talk about them
offline I just wanted to call out that I
think this is an incredible achievement
it is so clever the set of things that
they did to achieve this enormous
Improvement so shout out to them and it
does mean that if you had heard a rumor
that Colbert was Impractical to use
because the index was too large and the
latency was too long I think it's not
true anymore the indices are small
because of quantization and this is that
picture of latency so give it a shot
I have one more model but let me take
questions yeah did you have a question
oh sorry I just had a question
okay cool yeah I'm happy to talk more
The Plaid paper is full of tricks and
things like that
I don't want to take up too much time I
definitely want to give Sid plenty of
time to talk about models so let me just
show you one more this is blade this is
also ingenious it'll get you thinking in
a new way okay so for splayed I wrote
sequence at the bottom because we're
going to do this for both queries and
documents this process and crucially
here I have the vocabulary I've only
represented seven tokens but if it was
bird it would be like thirty thousand
okay
so we again process the text into the
output States
T1 through T3 there
and then we form all these scores
and the scores are determined by this
thing here that's s i sub J so we're
going to apply a linear layer to the
encoding those output States
and we're going to combine it with the
embedding for these vocabulary items
with a bias
so if you strip away the details you can
see that this is like a DOT product of
these states with all of these values
here in our vocabulary
and then splade is the sum of that and
so you can think of that as summing
across all the document tokens and so
what we've got in that orange column
there is a probably very sparse Vector
that represents this text down here with
respect to our vocabulary
so this is a lot like
term based work of old right this is a
lot like a TF IDF representation except
it was done in the neural space so we
should get the advantages of being with
a semantic model
and then the similarity value is just
the splayed representation that is this
representation here for the query dot
product with the document and the loss
is the one that we've been using all
along
so
you do the display process both with the
query and with the document and then
okay cool yeah there's a bunch and it
looks similar in my document but this is
great let me review what you just said
there's a bunch of new things sequence
not query or document because we do this
for both kinds and of course we can do
all the documents ahead of time
the big twist is that we're scoring
these sequences with respect to the
vocabulary and we are essentially
getting in semantic space because this
is an embedding space here and this is a
contextual embedding space here scores
for each query term with respect to the
whole vocabulary
that gives us this big presumably pretty
sparse vector and their optimization
further encourages sparsity
and then the similarity value is the dot
product of those for queries and for
documents
so it has some Hallmarks of late
interaction
except it is interacting the text
representations with the vocabulary kind
of like what you get with tfidf
and this model is outstanding
you saw it in some of my of my slides
before very impressive and it's also a
new way of thinking which I really like
here's a bunch of more recent
developments and one theme of them I
won't go through them is just that
people are working hard finally on
making these models more efficient so a
big theme of this is not just obsession
with accuracy but also obsession with
especially latency
thank you
and then finally for that paper that I
mentioned before we did a bunch of
systematic investigations of different
approaches you can see bm25 DPR Colbert
and some splayed models here and these
are all kind of variants of these models
where people have worked hard to
optimize them
there's lots of tables like this in the
paper let me just draw out a few
comparisons bm25 is the only solution
that could run on this tiny Hardware
here we couldn't even run the other
systems that's why it's alone in its own
little block there
and it costs nothing
right but it's not that successful
either success at 10 is low relative to
the rest when we move here this is sort
of interesting these two Colbert models
achieve very similar performance if you
look all the way to the right except one
of them is double the latency of the
other one
for this hardware and so you might
wonder do I really need this extra
point of performance
if I'm going to have to wait that long
and then if you look to splade so splade
is below Colbert V2 small
but its latency is a quarter or
something of the Colbert V2 small
so maybe you care more about that and
not so much about the success and then
if you compare these two splades right
they have the same performance
um but if you just jack up the hardware
a little bit
then you get much lower latency
but look how much the price went up
it went up for all of them with this
heavy duty Hardware uh
yeah so this is the space that you're
actually operating in I'll we'll talk
later about how we might more
systematically integrate all these
scores I think this is enough now to get
you thinking about all of these
dimensions and
they are the Plaid colberts yeah pretty
expensive there luckily in the paper we
show that you never need a GPU for
Colbert I believe you just so you can
always use cheaper Hardware
uh
yeah but those costs do look scary
hahaha
the final section of this is just some
data sets I think I don't need to go
through it because you have it as a
resource if you want to get started in
neural information retrieval you've got
t-rec Ms Marco and then there are a
bunch of new benchmarks that are
designed to assess systems out of the
box that is zero shot beer is great
latte is great for long-tailed uh topic
stratified evaluation and then this xor
tie dye is cool because this is
multilingual and I know you have
expressed interest in multilingual stuff
this could be a great playground for
doing that with kind of QA and retrieval
like open QA as we've been doing it
bunch of other topics I think the bottom
line here is just again this is like a
refrain in this class nlu and IR are
back together again after being apart
for so long and this is having profound
implications for research and Technology
development so this is absolutely a very
exciting moment to participate in this
research because there is so much
Innovation yet to happen and it is
having such an impact on research and
also out in the wider world
excellent all right Sid want to take
over
so it's cool is like retrieval isn't
just hitting nlu it's hitting everywhere
like vision and Robotics as of like this
week uh we're starting to use retrieval
methods to do
like what's the best way to figure out
how to do a new task uh maybe retrieve
some examples of a robot or a human
doing the same task and then generating
your actions so cool stuff
cool all right
let's see if this works
yeah all right
so
I'm going to kind of pick up
or try to pick up where I left off last
week and kind of give you this Evolution
this history lesson on how we got to the
Transformer
and then go from there into tips and
tricks training big models generally
um and then end with like a small little
teaser on fine tuning and parameter
efficient tuning so you can use that in
your projects down the road
cool so just to kind of Blaze past
things I kind of started by talking
through
um you know where things were pre-2017
when the Transformer paper came out on
both the RNN and the CNN side and kind
of tied a lot of the Innovation around
the Transformer to uh how modern uh
convolutional neural Nets specifically
residual Nets were working
um and kind of the connections there
were closer than the connections to rnns
uh kind of walk through how we got to
the self-attention block
um with this fancy code which is
basically just saying like you're
splitting your heads and you can kind of
think of your heads in a self-attention
block as the different kind of kernels
or filters in a CNN layer
um and then kind of closing with like
this full self-attention block where
we're actually doing the RNN style
attention
um and then this question of this
non-linearity that we're adding at the
end because without this non-linearity
and this sort of MLP that we're adding
to the end of each Transformer block
we're really just doing weighted
averages of linear transforms of values
okay
so
if we kind of take this as ground truth
you know starting point for what a
Transformer block looks like very much
inspired by the ideas of cnns and rnns
with the tension at the time
we have this residual connection here
um which is kind of just adding X over
and over again as we stack more and more
layers together there's a problem can
anyone spot the problem in this
implementation by itself
so the problem is that activations blow
up we keep adding the same input over
and over again as we go deeper
eventually uh specifically in the RNN
attention layer when we take this dot
product between the queries and the keys
we're going to get overflow
um and so we need to do something about
that right so while the first part of
kind of building the Transformer layer
is very very much inspired by history
the second part is just trying to make
sure it doesn't fail and doesn't blow up
and doesn't crash when we try training
it so what's one thing that we can do to
kind of avoid the sort of
blow up of our activations
um so layer normalization so layer
normalization
um maybe batch norm and learn Norm were
covered earlier on is a very very simple
idea along each feature Dimension we're
just going to normalize so that each
feature has mean zero standard deviation
one
which means that every time we add a
residual connection we're going to
normalize so that everything comes back
to a decent space we're still able to
learn the kind of same level of
expressivity we care about
we're just not necessarily going to you
know keep blowing up or growing the
magnitude of our activations
um and what that looks like is you know
two calls to nn.layernorm uh with the
dimensionality of our Transformer and
then adding that into a res block we're
just going to normalize each X before we
pass it into the attention and the MLP
layers respectively
now there's a problem with this that
isn't obvious and actually wasn't
obvious to the people building
Transformers at the time it wasn't
really explained kind of until three
years later which is that
um you have optimization issues when you
do this specifically if you just try to
optimize the naive Transformer with this
layer Norm in place with kind of
conventional ml wisdom right which is
like learning rate Decay or a constant
learning rate
um bad things happen specifically I'm
going to use the hug and face emojis my
stand-in for a Transformer
um
stuff happens the optimization crashes
it's either explode ingredients it's
either vanish ingredients if you have
someone in 2018 or 2019 or 2020 they
would tell you one or the others
happening but there are definitely no
gradients that are like stable
throughout the training process
so you introduced this kind of weird
thing it kind of comes out of almost
nowhere which is like this transform
this like warm-up schedule
that you see a lot of the time uh in
like any code for training or even
fine-tuning Transformers these days
now this is actually just like fun
because I have the time I'm gonna like
go through it who came up with this
thinking I'm thinking like I think I
remember in the this money at all paper
they had like a weird learning rate but
I don't remember so it is in the it is
in the original Transformer paper it's
like the main thing that they get to get
get this stably so it's one of the
authors that came up with it but um if
you actually run a get blame on the
first ever Transformer code base from
Google the tensor to tensor code base
like in the very first commit in like
you know the ARG parse like uh flags for
the different optimizers you use uh
there's one option just called gnome
after gnome Shazier uh and in the
annotated Transformer like the very
first like blog post that's what the
optimizer is called it's called No
mopped uh in Sasha rusher's code and
it's called The Gnome Optimizer for a
really long time until they just decide
to call it just like you know uh linear
warm up cosine decay uh and so Noam
Shazier kind of came up with it and if
you were to kind of go back and think
about like the sorts of problems and the
you know papers he was working on at the
time he was actually doing a lot of
stuff with the different types of
like uh gradient descent optimizers like
RMS prop add a factor came out like a
year after the Transformer paper came
out
and he was really like interested in
like looking at this problem of like huh
okay uh weights seemed to be or like if
you just really inspect the gradients
early on with like this layer Norm thing
variant seems to be high and you kind of
want to burn that in and he's seeing
this for lstm so he's kind of doing this
already for his lstm work
um and then you just like all right
let's try this it worked and no one
really questioned it
um it breaks conventional machine
learning wasn't like why am I warming up
my learning rate before I'm bringing it
down right like if I'm optimizing some
surface I kind of like want to start you
know kind of high move in and then like
maybe anneal it as I get closer to my
minimum
uh but no one is able to explain why
until three years later a paper comes
out that kind of like steps through the
specifics of training a Transformer
model on some data like synthetic data
with the atom Optimizer and actually tie
it to the layer normalization layers
that we just added you know we fixed one
problem we added another right so up top
we have kind of you know good gradients
right so on the left here is the
gradient magnitude and here's the update
magnitude so the gradients that are
computed and the updates that are
actually applied to the weights with
warm up in blue in red we have the same
thing but without warm-up and what ends
up happening is that gradients go to
zero somehow as you train it's actually
a weird graph because like as you're
coming forward in time is like as you're
creating more and more so this is kind
of like starting out and then like this
is kind of
and this is kind of like
um towards the you know wherever
training becomes unstable
and then your updates also become super
high variance so they do some math and
they kind of bound the update
um as a uh kind of like
proportional to the dimensionality of
the square root of the dimensionality of
your Transformer over the input Norm
that's coming in so if your input Norm
like if the size of your activation is
like sufficiently large your layer Norm
uh gradient is going to be completely
completely screwed
so what they end up doing is like okay
so warm up is necessary because it helps
you get the atom Optimizer to kind of
like move slowly enough at the beginning
so that we're kind of like saturating
the gradients we're like okay and then
when we kind of Go full throttle like
things are generally stable uh the
um activation storms aren't changing all
too much they're changing in a
predictable way and we can kind of start
to handle that and then conventional ml
kicks in but it's weird and it's also
weird that it took three years later and
some people still don't buy this
explanation but it's the best
explanation I've got to why we need that
warm-up
so General wisdom if you're fine tuning
or pre-training a Transformer warm up
for at least five percent of your full
training and then start to hang it just
helps
can I ask him if I don't know this paper
and so is there some data dependency or
some assumption about what the data will
be like because it seems like you said
hey look after a while we can relax
these updates are small or reasonable
but the world could do a lot to you and
if you shifted genres or data types they
would go back into being very unstable
yeah so I think in this paper they're
looking at like what I'll call nice data
sets they're looking at like the wikitex
choose of the world that are like
somewhat predictable it's all Wikipedia
homogenized language
uh but even when you're training the
modern like the really big Transformer
these days even after like all of these
tricks you're still gonna have like bad
batches just like really really
unpredictable things that are low
likelihood under your model that are
going to cause big updates in the middle
of training that are going to completely
crash your run so this happened tons of
times while we were creating like the
355 million parameter models this
happened uh every time you're trading
any big model in like the 1 billion plus
parameter range so the Luther AI folks
like this happens all of the time the T5
models uh have this thing uh in like one
of the like notes in like the GitHub
repository for like training a T5 which
is like huh if you if training fails
rewind to the latest checkpoint
re-randomize your data order and then
try again and it won't crash and that's
kind of how modern uh ml or most modern
language models are trained right now we
don't know how to avoid it yet we think
it's side to the data we can't isolate
it so why not just reroll and try again
eventually you'll just keep making
progress
cool
so
question in fact the uh I mean what do
the different colors represent yeah so
the question was uh what the different
colors represent so up top is blue with
the kind of traditional uh Transformer
learning rate so warm up and then
go down red is uh the
um no warm up let's just start the
learning rate high and then taper so red
is bad blue is good
inside the graph I mean like a dark red
would be more uh yeah so the way you
kind of interpret this graph and the
paper is linked in kind of at the bottom
of the slide but uh you can think of
like the furthest back
um like magnitude is like this is like
basically plotting like the you know
mean standard deviation of the updates
across layers uh the furthest back is
like batch zero as you get further in
you get to like batch 100 or batch 400
or whatever
yeah
question I wonder to what extent like
the the warm-up and the rate
then because I I've run into some
problems where
like I found that using add a Max of the
infinity Norm will work because I've got
this level of Dropout or whatever is
there any guidance of like all these big
hyper parameters that go into like
this tune where if I pull one lever I
should be pushing one down or choose
this Optimizer I should do another
because it feels like
I mean
taking three years it feels a little bit
like a wild west which is what it is
yeah so so if I were to paraphrase your
question it's like if you decide to
change anything about the current recipe
like change your Optimizer change
Dropout change your learning rate are
there rules of thumb for what else you
need to change to get things to to work
no
um it is
so kind of part of like why I I kind of
LED with like how we got to here I'm
kind of starting from like the
historical context was kind of to unpack
a lot of this folk knowledge because
it's still at the point where optimizing
these models especially as we go bigger
uh is kind of still concentrated in the
minds and like experience of like a very
small number of people because like
who's trained a seven billion parameter
language model or who's trained a 100
billion Premier language model where
does that skill set come from when
you're talking about a training run that
costs you know millions of dollars to
develop plus you know however much the
compute costs
um how many things are you really going
to be trying at the end what things can
you extrapolate from so Folks at openai
have definitely done like scaling laws
research where they're trying these
different things in some bounded search
space
but if you were to invent like a brand
new Optimizer that kind of looks at like
you know maybe second third fourth order
moments of your gradients maybe do
something fancy relative to like you
know how things are changing over time
and you were to just try and apply it to
you know the biggest language model you
could train I have no idea what I would
tell you in terms of like what things
you should change Beyond like some
obvious things like maybe don't set the
learning rate to be ridiculously high
I'm starting out
um if you have a batch of data that's
like let's just say during training you
find you come across a bad batch of data
that happens to cause like the
destabilization with ingredients
um and then you rewind back to your
checkpoint and you take that same exact
batch of data but instead of run like
running it through training when
gradients are enabled if you just run it
through imprints well that bad batch of
data have caused like anomalous behavior
from the model during inference or is it
strictly just a back propagation issue
so when we debug or when we debug this
so we a couple years ago trained like
some by today's standards really really
small language models but like 124
million to 355 million scale we were
noticing this problem
um the way we debugged it was that like
looking at the gradients which didn't
tell us much but then we just like
looked at activation Norms per layer and
that's how we actually debug this right
so looking at the forward pass looking
at the magnitudes of each layer like
where we thought we could possibly be
overflowing or under underflowing that's
exactly kind of how we debugged it but
we didn't debug it at the batch level we
debugged it as a kind of function of
time right because like a single batch
isn't going to perturb everything a
series of batches like maybe two three
who knows how many eventually you're
going to fall under some trajectory
where things get bad your activations
blow up
so we would be able to deterministically
rewind to that checkpoint then
determines like step through training
and like log every activation
which is expensive but like that's how
we were able to get to the bottom of the
problem
but I don't think we have tools for
actually figuring out like which batch
of data was or which sequence of batches
of data or the actual you know triggers
for that behavior
specifically about like if the same data
that causes destabilization and training
can cause like anomalous Behavior here
just like a normal form of task um it
probably would
um and you know there's some more recent
work about like how to quantize these
models like how to get a Transformer
that's trained with like 16-bit
Precision to like train or to run with
like 8-bit Precision by like you know
intelligently like bucketing
um floats from tin detmers who's a PhD
student up at UW he has this theory on
something called outlier features that
show up in these really big models that
kind of try and get at this but more of
an art than a science right now
yeah
okay so are we done now that we fixed
this like layer Norm stuff the learning
rate stuff all of the stuff you have to
transform to work kind of right so like
over the last few years like training
has been stable people want to like milk
the most of the Transformer you know
um especially as they scale up so they
do a couple things so one
um when you're training and attention
layer and you're projecting to queries
and keys uh at sufficient scale the bias
term in each like linear layers like WX
plus b you can get rid of the B's
because like it's not really doing
anything and it saves a little bit of
compute so let's get rid of them it's
like that's like the first thing they
throw out they're different activations
that have been invented and different
types of
um like
cool ways to just better fit your data
so there's this like swish glue so a
gated linear unit actually defines like
a separate weight Matrix as part of the
activation
um and then a swish is like the it's
like a sigmoid activation that applies
to one part of the weight and not the
other I'll have code for all of this it
works better
um this is actually the activation of
choice now in most Transformer
implementations so a lot more was
trained with this Palm was trained with
this
um works really well
um one thing that folks noticed is that
moving the layer Norm to happen you know
uh
before you actually feed it through the
attention or the MLP layers instead of
after uh is a more stabilizing force is
actually kind of important also a layer
Norm has trainable weights so some
papers decide to be like you don't
actually need you know these trainable
parameters for mean invariants you can
actually just like divide by the mean
square or the RMS of like your tire
activation feature
all things to just get rid of irrelevant
flops because we're creating massive
models and we're trying to do the bigger
the model on the compute that we have
um oh yeah here's the code for like a
switch glue activation and an RMS Norm
so switch glue is like so the silly is
like basically a sigmoid a projection
layer is basically saying like let's
take this input feature project it into
like two separate chunks one chunk
becomes like a gating value kind of like
in a gated recurrent unit in like the
RNN literature and one becomes the
actual value you apply the sigmoid to
the gate and then multiply it element
wise with a value and you get your new
thing works really well and our an RMS
Norm is like literally just dividing by
the norm of the vector instead of like
trying to learn anything fancy
cool this is what the modern transform
looks like
so
that's it for the evolution of the
Transformer as far as I know
nothing in the last two weeks have like
changed drastically from this
in the last two weeks to what extent
let's say we are doing a fine tune
instead of like the full train or we're
doing like Laura on top of it how would
we would we still want to follow these
kinds of guidelines or are these
specific to just doing all of the data
doing a whole pre-train yeah so question
is you know what of this
um do we really need if we're fine
tuning or if we're kind of doing like
parameter revision finding like is this
only necessary for pre-training so um
I've started using the switch glue
instead of like any other activation
like everywhere even for like a two
layer MLP
um tends to work better
um so take that with a grain of salt
everything else you can probably not
care about
um the RMS Norm the pre-norm is probably
just like a general rule of thumb if
you're adding any Transformer layers
just because it is like demonstrably
more stable but other than that no
other questions here before we move to
how to train on lots and lots of compute
cool so let's talk about training at
scale
so
um
I'll start with a story my story okay so
I am
not old but I have uh you know seen a
few things as far as you know language
models have gone right so like 2018 is
when I I think did my first deep
learning tutorial I trained a mnist like
you know the typical like two layer
four-layer MLP for classification
uh there's actually a line there it's
the hundred thousand parameter line
um that's 2018.
um as I kind of start my PhD in 2019 I'm
you know doing more NLP stuff I'm
looking at like word vectors rnns some
more sophisticated things I'm getting up
to a million parameters 2020 I kind of
you know Branch out from like the small
NLP stuff I'm doing to like you know
more uh intensive NLP looking at tasks
like summarization training uh models
with like 10 million parameters and then
by 2021 like the biggest Prim like the
biggest models I I was training was like
when I switched into multi-modality
robotics looking at visual question
answering 18 million parameters and at
the time the standard pipeline for me
and I think this was the standard
pipeline for a lot of grad students that
I talked to at then it's like I'd be
able to train most of my things on one
GPU or you know even my laptop CPU
um for like a maximum of a few hours
right like that is what a training run
would take at least for like most of the
things I was doing on a day to day
um but you know in 2021 uh Percy's like
hey this gpt3 thing seems cool let's at
least figure out if we can get an
academic lab to like try and train a
gpt2 like the earlier generation so
clocking in at like 124 million
parameters which is notably an order of
magnitude bigger than anything I trained
at the time so why I decided to do this
is still be on me but I learned a lot of
useless things
uh one of the useful things that I
learned is that um
training a 124 million parameter model
on a decent GPU that we had access to at
the time with a batch size greater than
four would go out of memory
which is bad because a batch size of
four is small and we wanted to ideally
train with like a batch size of 512.
so
um there was a simple trick and it's
called gradient accumulation which is
like I'm going to run batch sizes of
four
um however many times it takes to get
into 512 and then do an update after
processing all of those batches
sequentially so I'm just going to keep
accumulating the gradients and pytorch
makes it really easy it's just a for
Loop and an if statement
um but if you do the maths like 100 days
to train on that single GPU for 400 000
steps so how do we go from this clock of
100 days to something reasonable that's
what we're going to talk about
so
the scaling toolbox at least as far as
you know
we were concerned kind of ended up
looking like you know three
different parts
across 16 gpus because Percy and Chris
Ray and I think Chris and Dan and Chris
Manning and the NOP group decided to
invest up front and like really powerful
GPU machines so we could actually train
on like 16 gpus at once
um
for reference 16 gpus on AWS to just
rent on an hourly basis is 56 bucks an
hour now
56 bucks an hour uh if you you know want
to just like sit on them but if you're
willing to like let anyone who you know
has the money and like wants to sit on
them like preempt you you can get them
for 16 bucks an hour
so like across four days like that's not
the worst it's like not great
um but totally doable
so the scaling toolbox we ended up
looking at was you know data parallelism
you can think about this as like
literally just divide and conquer how do
I just
paralyze work across all of these gpus
instead of one
um mixed Precision training uh and we're
going to talk you know a little bit
about what that means
um and then this you know interesting
idea called zero redundancy which is
about minimizing the memory footprint of
training
um and then later on as you want to
scale up to you know hundreds of
billions of parameters on you know 256
512 1024 2048 gpus
um we'll talk like there are things like
that come handy like model parallelism
uh there are things to consider like
hardware and software limitations
um but
some of you might be here looking at me
which is like okay do I need any of this
stuff if I'm not training really big
models like I'm just fine-tuning stuff
um
a lot of these
trick tips and tricks like you may not
have access to you know 100 gpus or even
you know eight but you might have access
to two or four comes in handy
um a lot of the ideas here are still
ideas that I'm using when I'm training
um stuff on my laptop or when I'm trying
to run inference with like the latest
big model that is publicly released so
it's useful
but you know please ask questions if
things become too hazy or too not useful
for people relying on collab data
parallel
so collab yeah collab you're still
limited to single GPU and I'm guessing
zero redundancy might help uh so mixed
Precision would help
um kind of uh definitely for running
inference and zero it on C would also
help running inference
uh so zero Dundee has like an add-on
that they wrote up in a paper later
called zero Infinity which is like what
if I didn't put all my weights on the
GPU at once what do I would you put some
of them on my seat in like CPU Ram or
even in like nvme SSD storage so
actually turning your laptop into a more
powerful Workhorse than a collab GPU
cool so uh this is a toy example kind of
going through
capitalism
uh
we're running low on time-ish so uh this
is mnist with an MLP we're trying to do
classification uh it's kind of the
typical
um pytorch workflow I'm going to define
a an end dot module I'm going to define
a batch size a data loader that's going
to load from the torque Vision data set
uh and then I'm just going to run uh you
know lots and less grading steps
uh the idea here is how do we paralyze
this across multiple
workers multiple gpus
um well that batch size you see there is
totally divisible especially given that
like what we're doing at the end when we
kind of compute the loss is just take an
average
an average of averages is still the
average that's that's the idea we're
going to work with the mean of means is
still you know the global mean
so just like in CPU land where you can
kind of think about like simdi
instructions like single instruction
multiple data right so it's like kind of
how most graphics and media operations
work on your laptops we're gonna now
think about like the spmd Paradigm I'm
going to write one program and it's just
going to automatically scale to being
split across however any machines
because we're going to split the data
across multiple machines
uh it seems hard but as of Pi torch 1.4
a lot of the hard parts are taken care
of for you these are the only lines you
need to change in the implementation two
of them are import statements
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to just
create something called a distributed
sampler which is going to automatically
partition our data across the number of
workers we Define upfront right we're
defining a world size of eight so that
means we're training on eight gpus so
this is going to partition our data into
eight different subsets that each worker
gets to go through
we're going to wrap our NN dot module
with like this nice little wrapper this
distributed data parallel wrapper which
is going to sync the gradients for us
behind this behind the scenes
um and then we're going to run this with
a special command called cortron which
is just going to inject a bunch of
environment variables so that we can you
know get some statistics about you know
our local rank who's the guy who should
be printing stuff to the screen who's
the guy who should be logging stuff
um where each worker lives
um and that's about it and you can do
all of this and you just paralyze it
naively across 16 gpus you get you know
not quite a 16x beat up because there is
you know some overhead from
communication
it's like seven days that's like cool it
was not good enough
because we were trying to train lots of
models reproducibly five seeds for like
10 different models types so uh like 50
models so we needed to go a little
faster than this
so let's talk about memory footprints
um when I am training any model with an
atom optimizer
uh how much memory does just storing
that model and the optimizer weights
take up
but so
in 32-bit Precision our model is going
to have you know parameters where each
parameter is stored and with 32 bits
that's a float gradients 32 bits
and now your Optimizer is also going to
do this weird thing we're going to have
a copy its own separate copy of the
parameters like kind of duplicating a
little bit of work there that's also 32
bits and then atom tracks momentum
select the and variants like the first
and second order of the gradients so
that's another 64 bytes or bits right
there
so the lower bound on static memory just
like storing this stuff on a GPU is 20
bytes times the number of parameters
that you have
um that this doesn't include activations
at all for these larger transform models
but I want to keep around every like
buffer like every you know intermediate
Matrix as I pass it through the network
that takes up way more space but like
this is at least it gives us something
that we can reason about
the trading implications of this is that
if I want to fit a model with a billion
parameters that's going to take about 18
gigs resting
um 31 gigs of GPU Ram with a batch size
of one
which is problematic because most gpus
then capped out of 24 gigs the really
expensive ones now have like 40 or 80
but this is still bad
175 billion parameters would take three
terabytes of ram not storage just Ram
without activations with activation it's
probably looking like 10 terabytes good
luck
uh the numbers in Boulder batch size of
one uh numbers on both are just like
just putting it on the thing
um and things you should know about
floats uh it was a standard defined in
this IEEE document you have a one bit
sign 8-bit exponent 23 bit like
scientific notation like all the stuff
happened that happens after the exponent
a wide range up to 20 38 and the
question is like do you need that range
answer is like
kind of but not really
so the mixed Precision memory footprint
if I'm training a model in mixed
Precision what that means is that I'm
just going to run everything in a
forward pass and part of the backwards
pass in
16-bit Precision instead of 32-bit
precision
notably what that means is like now I'm
starting my parameters and 16 bits my
gradients in 16 bits all of that those
intermediate activations that take up
lots and lots and lots of memory
especially as you go bigger are halved
which is great
but the weird part about mixed Precision
is not everything is mixed Precision so
your Optimizer to stably update your
model still needs the 32-bit parameter
copies or 32-bit momentum 32-bit
variants
uh but and you've kind of like but
you've dropped four bytes and those four
bytes are kind of useful
yet training with mixed Precision uh at
least a couple years ago and it's still
mostly true now is still way faster than
training with full precision
and the reason for that is
most Nvidia gpus starting with the Volta
cards I started shipping with these
things called tensor course
tensor cores are basically the
individual logical units on a GPU that
are responsible for Matrix multiplies
your GPU is really good at accelerating
neural network training because it's
really good at doing Matrix multiplies
these things are optimized for 4x4 to
you know 16 by 16 size charts if you're
training in 16-bit Precision you can
actually end up using way more tensor
cores than if you were using 32-bit
precision
and so you're able to get a ton of speed
UPS just because you're able to tap into
the hardware the underlying Hardware
system more frequently as of the Ampere
style card so like the a100s or
um you know the more recent like 30 90s
30 90 tis 40 90s
those start shipping with these cores
that that are able to do you know
float32 Precision but are still even
faster for 16-bit precision so when you
can train with 16-bit precision
all right uh the shaves a day off of our
small scale training this shaves off way
more uh especially as you go bigger
um and now the final bit is how do we
eliminate the redundancies right so in
standard data parallelism
yeah
the 32-bit
so when you are estimating the gradients
Precision matters more you want that
full range specifically you want uh that
you know those like 23 bits that kind of
correspond to like everything that has
data to be meaningful because while the
full range of like flow 32 is really
really big it actually can't be super
precise
like kind of in like the zero one range
for example
uh so you kind of want as much there as
possible to kind of Ensure precision
okay so zero redundancy standard data
parallelism you're basically storing
everything on each GPU key idea is uh I
don't need to store everything on every
GPU I just need to store some things on
every GPU
so the model gets to say on each GPU
because the model has to do all the work
but the gradients I can just split
across the number of devices that I have
so half my gradients if I have two gpus
go on one device half of them go on the
other device
same with the optimizer States half of
them go one device half of them go on
the other device with this model of zero
redundancy you're actually not adding
any extra communication cost you just
get free memory because you're just
intelligently partitioning things across
devices
notice that this scales uh you
use less and less memory as you add more
and more machines right so this is kind
of like the biggest trick to start
training like 1 billion to 10 billion
parameter plus models
and now when you add this you're at
three days
you have to tell it what because this
would this would require like things
being slightly out of sync to optimize
do you have to like so this actually
doesn't require anything out of sync
because in a backwards pass with
distributed data parallel the
um the individual updates already have
to be synced across processes right if
you take the loss across averaged across
all processes that means that the
gradient to apply have to be transferred
as well
so this just basically does that work
for you
uh we're gonna wrap up uh you hit a
communication wall Matrix multiplies
stop fitting on a device so you start
charging them and then you have to start
scheduling things wisely and yeah great
fine tuning in friends there is a great
library that you should use called PFT
from hug and face it's great and that's
it